Traduttore: Lucia Zanichelli
Revisore: Silvia Fornasiero
Ero al quinto mese di gravidanza,
avevo 24 anni
quando sono quasi caduta in depressione.
Non facevo altro che piangere ogni giorno
Poi, a un mese dal parto,
le cose sono cominciate
ad andare un po' meglio
ma la Lucia frizzante e allegra
che c'era un tempo
non la trovavo più.
La vita è andata avanti
tra grandi gioie, dolori
un po' come per tutti.
Finchè un giorno una mia amica
decide di regalarmi un corso
di "risata incondizionata".
Non sapevo bene di cosa si trattasse
ma non ridevo da così tanto tempo
che decisi di accettare all'istante.
Così, cominciando a ridere
prima che la vita mi desse
un motivo per farlo,
mi sono finalmente sentita di nuovo viva.
E ho incominciato a sentire emozioni
che non provavo più da tantissimo tempo.
Oggi dopo quattro anni sono ancora qui
e continuo a ridere,
aiuto anche altre persone a farlo
anche quando la vita non va
esattamente come vorremo.
Ma una cosa ho capito nel tempo:
che a farmi stare bene erano sì le risate,
ma soprattutto era
l'interazione giocosa con gli altri.
È così che mi sono appassionata
al tema del gioco: giocando.
E c'è una storia in particolare
che mi ha colpito molto
e mi ha fatto davvero rendere conto
di quanto giocare sia fondamentale,
vitale per il nostro benessere.
È la storia di questo ragazzo qua.
Charles Whitman era
un giovane studente di ingegneria
e ex tiratore scelto dei Marines
che il primo agosto del '66
sale sulla torre dell'università
di Austin in Texas
e comincia a sparare sulla folla.
Ucciderà 16 persone
e ne ferirà gravemente 30,
dando inizio
alla tristemente famosa stagione
degli omicidi di massa in America.
All'epoca Steward Brown,
questo psichiatra,
venne incaricato dallo Stato
di scoprire quali fossero le ragioni
per cui persone, apparentemente normali,
all'improvviso diventavano
dei serial killer.
Intervistò 26 detenuti,
tutti condannati per omicidio,
e scoprì una cosa incredibile:
quasi tutti erano stati deprivati
del gioco quando erano bambini.
Purtroppo questa era la storia
anche di Whitman,
il cui padre, che era un militare,
lo obbligava solo a fare compiti utili,
mai a giocare.
Da allora Whitman ha intervistato
più di 6.000 persone
e fondato il National Institute for Play,
che studia appunto il gioco,
ed è arrivato a una conclusione,
piuttosto inquietante anche:
la deprivazione dal gioco
durante l'infanzia
può compromettere gravemente
la felicità e l'adattamento sociale
una volta che diventiamo adulti.
Giocare è un bisogno biologico,
primario e innato.
Quasi tutti gli animali giocano.
Guardate qua.
Le caprette giocano, le tigri,
gli orsi, i lupi, i panda,
e noi, come esseri umani, siamo
gli animali che giocano di più di tutti.
Il bisogno di giocare
è scritto nei nostri geni.
Perché? Perché ci permette
di sviluppare delle competenze
fisiche, sociali e emotive
in un ambiente sicuro.
I cuccioli di leone, per esempio,
giocano alla lotta
per poter diventare bravi cacciatori
senza rischiare la vita.
Noi cuccioli di uomo giochiamo
per introiettare queste competenze
che saranno fondamentali
una volta diventati adulti.
Giocare è un tratto dell'evoluzione
a tutti gli effetti.
E tanti di noi continuano a farlo
anche da grandi.
Come lo facciamo? In tantissimi modi,
ad esempio, c'è chi gioca
con il gioco della scrittura
che è un gioco della fantasia;
con la pittura;
il primo speaker gioca viaggiando;
chi con i mirtilli, come dicevamo prima.
È un po' il nostro ikigai.
Perché lo facciamo?
Anzi no, prima vi dico questa cosa:
la neotenia,
questo termine che sembra
un po' una malattia ma non lo è,
è una cosa molto bella,
vuol dire letteralmente
"Ritenzione di tratti dell'immaturità".
Noi riteniamo questi tratti
dalla nostra giovinezza,
come la voglia di giocare,
perché ci fanno bene.
Appunto, lo facciamo perché
ci dà dei superpoteri,
ci permette di stringere relazioni
di qualità e durature,
nutre la nostra immaginazione,
la creatività,
abbassa i livelli di cortisolo,
di adrenalina, gli ormoni dello stress,
nutre la cooperazione,
ci insegna ad avere fiducia negli altri,
in poche parole, ci rende
delle persone più resilienti.
Voglio vedere,
mi accendete un attimo le luci in sala?
Voglio vedere chi tra di voi,
Luci?
si considera una persona giocosa?
Avete notato che ho la bocca secca?
Bevo un attimo, un po' d'emozione.
Mamma mia, le prime file,
mi fate un po' paura.
Benissimo, grazie.
Non tutti giustamente,
sto scherzando naturalmente,
forse non vi ritenete giocosi
perché non sapete ancora
a che gioco vi piace giocare.
Ad ogni modo, ci sono
delle persone playfobiche
che hanno proprio la fobia del gioco.
E un ambiente nello specifico
è il più playfobico di tutti
ed è il mondo del lavoro.
Lavorare per definizione è duro, faticoso,
una palla, brava, una cosa brutta,
considerata negativa.
Perchè? Ve lo dico io
Tanti motivi storico-culturali,
uno tra tutti è
la Prima Rivoluzione Industriale.
Con la meccanicizzazione del lavoro...
Sono troppo avanti, poi si arrabbiano.
Con la meccanicizzazione del lavoro,
il dipendente diventa
un ingranaggio perfetto
della macchina che è l'organizzazione.
Deve essere veloce, efficiente
e parlare il meno possibile, giusto?
Oggi le cose sono un po' cambiate,
ma purtroppo il modello meccanicista
è ancora tanto diffuso.
E per modello meccanicistico
intendo organizzazione uguale macchina,
dipendenti ingranaggi.
In realtà l'azienda è un organismo
vivente molto complesso
che cambia di continuo.
La demotivazione oggi è ai massimi storici
e gli ambienti di lavoro sono
saturi di frustrazione e sfiducia
che vanno poi a generare conflitti
più o meno espliciti.
Ecco in questo tipo di ambienti
giocare o qualsiasi eccesso di allegria
sono visti come una vera minaccia.
Perché? Perché o stai lavorando
o te la stai spassando.
Per forza.
Per fortuna questo modello ha portato a...
è emersa una crisi sempre più evidente
e tante organizzazioni
hanno cominciato una transizione
verso modelli più sostenibili,
inclusivi, umani,
perché appunto, ci siamo resi conto
che le aziende sono fatte di persone,
non di macchine.
Oggi, in Italia e nel mondo
stanno nascendo
le cosiddette organizzazioni positive;
sono aziende che hanno realmente a cuore
il benessere e la felicità
dei propri dipendenti.
E mi sembra una sincronia bellissima
che proprio oggi, in questo istante,
mentre noi stiamo qui,
si stia formando la prima classe
di Chief Happiness Officers,
i primi 50 manager della felicità italiani
con l'Istituto italiano
per le organizzazioni positive,
con il quale collaboro
per portare le pratiche giocose
all'interno delle culture aziendali.
Ecco vedete, la mia ricerca
in qualche modo si incastra proprio qui,
in questa linea ascendente
che è l'interesse reale per l'umano.
Abbiamo detto che giocare
è un bisogno biologico primario,
ed è anche una variabile
della scienza della felicità.
Io con questo non voglio dire
che giocare sia la panacea di ogni male,
ma sicuramente
è un grande catalizzatore di processi,
un'enzima potentissimo
al servizio di clima,
cooperazione, motivazione, creatività.
Valore che nessuna azienda che oggi
vuole avere successo può dimenticare.
Mi sono sbagliata, ecco visto?
Ecco no, mi ero dimenticata.
Oggi voglio svelarvi anche
un segreto importantissimo
che vale 500 miliardi di dollari,
che sono i soldi
che ogni anno l'America spende
a causa della demotivazione
dei propri dipendenti.
Alzi la mano chi la mattina,
il lunedì mattina
è felicissimo di andare a lavorare.
Qualcuno c'è.
Questo è un freelance probabilmente.
Persone che hanno trovato
il proprio ikigai.
Alzatele bene queste mani.
Non tantissimi. Perché?
Perché le aziende non hanno ancora capito
quali sono i veri fattori
della motivazione.
Ve li voglio fare vedere.
Questa è la Self-Determination Theory
di Ryan e Deci.
Sono i fattori motivanti da un livello
più estrinseco a uno più intrinseco.
Una pressione economica:
lavoro per soldi. Molto basso
Poi abbiamo la pressione emotiva:
lavoro per avere un riconoscimento
emotivo, cibo emotivo.
Poi abbiamo il potenziale:
lavoro, sono motivato a lavorare
perché credo di poterlo fare,
di avere il potenziale per farlo.
Abbiamo poi lo scopo.
Sono state modificate
le slide ma non fa niente.
Lo scopo è lavoro per qualcosa
che va al di là della mia individualità,
qualcosa più grande di me.
Ma al primo posto che non è quello,
lì ci dovrebbe essere scritto due
ma non fa niente,
è, signori, il gioco.
Giocare, ma vi rendete conto?
Giocare è l'attività a maggiore
motivazione intrinseca che esista.
Quando gioco, non voglio
fare nient'altro,
voglio soltanto quello.
Se le aziende capissero che per motivare
davvero i propri dipendenti
dovrebbero portare un po' di cultura
del divertimento e del gioco
forse risolverebbero i problemi
in maniera un po' diversa.
Non è un caso se l'81% dei dipendenti
di aziende denominate "great", grandi,
tra le 100 milioni di aziende
per cui lavorare
hanno detto di lavorare
in un ambiente fun, divertente.
Allora, forse cominciamo a capire
che giocare non è proprio
sinonimo di perdere tempo.
Giocare è avere un atteggiamento
mentale completamente diverso,
che va a nutrire clima, cooperazione,
motivazione appunto dei nostri dipendenti.
Le persone hanno voglia
di fare bene il loro lavoro
se le facciamo stare bene.
Giocare è quindi una cosa molto seria.
E adesso,
secondo me nella vostra testa
ci saranno un sacco di interrogativi
Bene tutte queste cose
che mi stai dicendo,
ma quindi che dovrei fare?
Io lunedì vado a lavorare
e organizzo la partita a ruba bandiera?
Metto il naso rosso? Io non so nemmeno
raccontare barzellette.
Neanche io, tranquilli.
Non bisogna essere
per forza persone divertenti.
Questo mito è da sfatare.
Non bisogna essere
degli umoristi nati per saper giocare.
Io per esempio
non capisco proprio le battute.
Non le capisco, è vero.
Ho provato a stilare
una lista di quattro principi
che forse possono aiutarvi a portare anche
solo un pizzico di cultura del gioco.
Il primo principio è:
"Non esiste una taglia unica".
Non esiste uno stile di gioco
uguale per tutti.
Ognuno ne ha uno diverso.
Se ci fosse una ricetta,
io ve la darei volentieri, ma non c'è.
Dovete cercarla voi.
Quali sono gli ingredienti
per il vostro team?
Quindi la parola chiave
per questo principio è: chiedere.
Dovete chiedere, informarvi,
scoprire cosa appassiona i dipendenti.
Come fate a fare delle cose
che fanno bene a loro
se non sapete che cosa amano fare?
Dovete interessarvi genuinamente a loro.
Quest'azione da sola fa miracoli.
Miracoli.
Secondo principio: "Date il buon esempio".
Io capisco che i piani alti
dell'organizzazione
facciano un po' fatica
ad accettare questa idea del gioco
perché la paura di mettersi in ridicolo
potrebbe essere alta,
però ho una brutta notizia:
non c'è modo di chiedere a qualcuno,
ai propri dipendenti,
di diventare giocosi, gioiosi, allegri
se non siamo noi i primi
a sostenere il processo.
Dobbiamo fare in modo che la leggerezza
penetri a poco a poco nell'organizzazione.
E non dobbiamo pensare neanche
di fare chissà cosa.
Sapete cosa basterebbe?
Un sorriso in più.
Una pacca sulla spalla,
una sorpresa inaspettata,
uno sguardo sincero.
Ma lo dobbiamo fare noi.
Siamo noi gli agenti del cambiamento.
E soprattutto, terzo principio:
"Il cambiamento ha bisogno di tempo".
Non possiamo pensare
che nel giro di una settimana
la nostra azienda diventi una fucina
di divertimento, produttività e creatività
quando non lo è mai stata prima.
Dobbiamo essere pazienti,
cercare piano piano le soluzioni,
sfruttare la fantasia.
Naturalmente stiamo uscendo fuori
dalla zona di comfort
e quindi non per forza
le azioni che sceglieremo all'inizio,
se vogliamo intraprendere questo cammino,
che so essere difficile,
non funzioneranno.
Non potete abbattervi,
perché ogni cambiamento
che è duraturo nel tempo è lento.
Ultimo: "Work hard, Play hard".
No grazie.
Work hard, play hard,
forse lo avete sentito,
lo dicono un sacco nella Silicon Valley.
Lavora duramente, gioca duramente.
Cioè quando stai lavorando,
stai lavorando
e poi quando stai giocando, stai giocando.
Che è un po' in italiano, anzi,
in marchigiano si dice; "lu cuntintì",
cioè ti faccio lavorare
e poi, dopo, puoi andare a giocare.
Io non credo in questo.
Credo che il gioco e il lavoro
siano due dimensioni
che devono compenetrarsi.
Non può essere il gioco
il contraltare del lavoro,
ma lo spirito.
Le aziende spendono una fortuna
per i team building
che è giocare fuori dal lavoro.
Poi però quando tornano
è tutto uguale a prima.
La formazione del team dovrebbe essere
una prerogativa quotidiana.
Non è un caso se le più grandi
aziende di software,
quelle più all'avanguardia,
hanno installato dei tavoli da ping pong
e dei biliardini negli uffici.
O se Google permette ai propri dipendenti
di portare i cani sul posto di lavoro.
Lo stesso Richard Branson,
il fondatore del gruppo Virgin,
dice che il segreto del successo
della sua azienda
sia solo uno: il divertimento.
Possiamo fare tantissime cose
e forse proprio perché
ne possiamo fare tante
è difficile scegliere.
Però davvero dovete usare la fantasia,
capire cosa piace al vostro team
e provare, senza avere paura.
Potete, ad esempio, creare
un rito divertente per il cambio turno,
oppure scegliere un giorno a settimana
in cui vi vestite in maniera
un po' stravagante,
o ancora, celebrare
insieme al vostro team
un obiettivo raggiunto insieme.
Celebrare è importantissimo.
Dovete solo usare la fantasia
e far sì che il divertimento
entri a far parte, diventi un valore
della cultura aziendale.
Lei è la mia capra.
E vi invito a giocare.
Abbiamo tanto parlato di gioco, scusate,
e quindi ora adesso vi invito a giocare.
Chi non ha alzato la mano prima
adesso mi odia.
Ma tranquilli perché
sarà breve e indolore.
Vi devo presentare tre amici che sono:
la tigre,
la tigre è
chi si mangia la vita,
la persona che, nonostante
i problemi e la paura,
affronta la vita.
Siamo pronti? La tigre fa così, pronti?
Guardate! Roar!
Fatelo anche voi. Tre, due, uno, via!
Roar!
Bravissimi!
I fuochi d'artificio sono la creatività,
quei colori che escono dal cervello
la capacità di trovare
soluzioni creative e sostenibili
ai problemi che poi affronta la tigre.
I colori. Sono così i fuochi d'artificio:
Pum Pum wow! Ammazza quanti siete! Vai!
Pum! Pum!
[Pubblico: Wow!]
Bravissimi!
E infine c'è la persona, le relazioni.
Senza le relazioni tutto il resto
non avrebbe nessun senso.
L'intelligenza emotiva è così,
l'ho sintetizzata così: [Manda un bacio]
Vai! [Il pubblico manda un bacio]
Ripassiamo: Tigre!
[Il pubblico: Roar!]
Fuochi d'artificio!
[Il pubblico: Wow!]
Persona!
[Il pubblico manda un bacio]
Alzatevi in piedi.
Adesso vi metterete schiena contro schiena
con la persona più vicina a voi.
Vai! Velocemente che abbiamo poco tempo.
Le persone che rimangono da sole
alzino la mano,
velocemente, così vi vedo.
Chi rimane da solo,
guardatevi, accoppiatevi, vedetevi,
trovatevi tra di voi.
Velocemente, corretevi incontro.
Bene, adesso silenzio un attimo
che vi spiego cosa farete.
Inspirate profondamente.
Espirate profondamente.
Vi connettete con la persona dietro di voi
e pensate, silenzio in sala,
bla bla shh...
Dovete pensare a uno
di questi tre simboli:
o la tigre o la persona
o i fuochi d'artificio. Ci siete?
La cosa però che dovete fare
è connettervi davvero
con la persona dietro di voi
e provare a instaurare
un contatto telepatico.
Dovete riuscire a fare
lo stesso simbolo della persona.
Quando vi dirò il tre, vi girerete
e scoprirete se ce l'avete fatta
a instaurare questo contatto telepatico.
Siete pronti? Silenzio.
Ah! Naturalmente
se ce la fate, ragazzi,
dovete strapparvi i capelli,
cioè proprio "Mamma mia!"
Dovete celebrare!
Abbiamo detto che la celebrazione
è importante quindi: batti cinque,
vi prendete in braccio, baci, abbracci,
no cose zozze,
ma tutto il resto è accettabile.
Pronti?
Ci siete. Inspirate. Chiudete gli occhi.
Connettetevi.
State instaurando
una interazione telepatica.
Tigre, persona o fuochi d'artificio?
Tre, due, uno...
Via! Giratevi!
Fantastico!
Come è andata?
Chi ce l'ha fatta alzi la mano.
Tanti! Ma voi siete un po' più fortunati,
questa ala un po' meno?
Ce l'avete fatta anche voi?
Tanti, tantissimi!
Bravissimi, fatevi un applauso.
Sedetevi.
Vi dico un'ultima cosa e me ne vado.
C'è sempre un po' di scompiglio
dopo tigre, persona o fuochi d'artificio.
Uno scompiglio felice.
Signori, bla bla shh!
La leggerezza,
la leggerezza è una competenza
fondamentale in questo futuro che emerge
e che cambia alla velocità della luce.
Ogni piccolo cambiamento
ci rende dei passengers,
degli autostoppisti intergalattici.
Il viaggio che io vi propongo
va da un pianeta in cui il gioco
è il rischio da evitare,
a un altro pianeta,
in cui gli sguardi
e i sorrisi sono la norma.
Un pianeta in cui non abbiamo paura
di essere tigri, persone,
fuochi d'artificio.
Un pianeta in cui siamo felici,
non siamo felici quando abbiamo successo
esattamente il contrario:
cominciamo ad avere successo
proprio perché siamo felici;
perchè la felicità e il gioco
sono delle competenze, vanno allenate.
Stasera, quando tornate a casa,
penserete a tutte queste cose,
a tutti gli speech,
Io sarò contenta se proverete
a portare anche solo un pizzico
di cultura del divertimento
nei vostri posti di lavoro,
sia che siate dei manager,
dei CEO, dei dipendenti.
Qualsiasi cosa siate.
Però prima di fare questo,
vi chiedo un favore.
Spegnete i cellulari
e giocate soprattutto con i vostri figli,
perché è davvero importante.
Ce ne hanno un gran bisogno, ragazzi.
Buttatevi per terra e giocate con loro
Grazie!